[Music]
and welcome back to another amazing
episode of the careful boys and today we
got walter hong in the seat up what's up
everybody clams just won
go rams bo ram i saw you on instagram at
the super bowl
at that uh
angle that you said you liked to sit in
benzo yeah
i was i went dude let's go how was it
was the energy freaking crazy dude it
was it like you know okay i gotta tell
you a regular season game has more
energy only because it's filled with
rams fans
the super bowl is is a mixture of
bengals fans and super bowl fans
and celebrities yeah and celebrities and
the celebrities are you know they're in
their boxes and stuff so it's different
but so the energy i mean they entered
the super bowl energy is there but the
game energy is off it's not the same
what do you mean like it's it's like
when you have hardcore fans they're
watching the game but then fans that
that are just there they're like not no
though everyone they're all watching the
game it's just that when you're like a
regular season game when something bad
happens you know it's like boo and when
something great happens it's like yeah
and then if um if let's say half the
fans are for the other team the energy's
still there because they're focused and
there's like yeah but it's half booze
and half you guys at the same time you
don't really know which emotion you're
supposed to feel exactly but super bowl
you have a lot of people that are just
there as fans of the super bowl or
they're just there because it's a super
bowl so they just scream regardless of
yeah there's no rivalry there yeah or
they may not scream at all they may just
be like oh like that was a good play i
go for the hot dogs yeah hot dogs are
pretty fire there's hot dogs at the
footballs
actually actually the the hot dogs
inside aren't as good as the ones
outside
all the bacon wraps the bacon and wrap
ones and oh for real remember a long
time ago when it was illegal to for them
to do that you'd have like two or three
of them yeah now there's like 20. yo
this one on one side on one side dude i
heard they were kicking them all out
they didn't no oh because you know so in
the beginning when they were illegal you
know you know like literally like
someone will say cops yeah and then you
look and you turn back they're gone yeah
they're calling yeah yeah now i think
someone like some industrious innovator
just basically organized all of them and
so when you walk into into sofi there's
like 20 on the way in yeah like i'm
talking about right next to each other
like as close as we are doing the bell
peppers the cactus yeah all of that same
with staples or crypto.com arena
that's true because sometimes they'll
have like anime conventions whatever
conventions every time there's a
convention they'll be the hot dog people
ready to serve you know what they i wish
they had i forgot what's called that one
corn that the mexicans do
hello
yeah
i've only seen it once at the coliseum
and then i realized why they don't have
it this is my guess it's too messy it is
really messy so people don't buy it no
they don't want to do this no i don't
think it's the people i think it's the
the cleanup crew
oh because of if it's spilled that's my
guess yeah because it falls off so
they're like you can't do it oh yeah put
your cup now that's the key yeah the cup
is the key
oh don't they mix it in the cup yeah
that one's pretty [ __ ] good but i
like it on the cob though i do too yeah
i did too that's probably why you're
like
everywhere dude gets everywhere man the
hot dog people they're everywhere
because like i was at a blm protest and
they were right there serving the
activists dude that's legitimate
pandemic they're probably serving the
other side too they were serving
everybody dude because whoever wants to
be the guy who's taking the mask
from burning all these buildings i'm so
hungry arms
you see the line of people getting the
bacon wrap hot dogs la dogs and stuff
you get like a trump supporter that was
on one side you get a [ __ ] you know
he's like hold my place in line please
super cordial in mind
you got changed for a five yeah
it's like it's like no minorities but
can i get too big
build a wall but not yet that's how it
is
so a lot of us get haircuts at vins and
alhambra and they've been around for
like 20 30 years through like the whole
asian gang era and i was like dude has
this place ever been shot up or whatever
because like the sgv was filled with
rival games
and he says people would just roll in if
they see someone else there there's
enough respect they just bounce oh wow
start [ __ ] there because
because both sides need good haircuts so
no one wants to [ __ ] that [ __ ] up nope
oh my god that's cool man exhibiting
wisdom is fantastic that's what they
know i'm like oh wow they chose not to
kill somebody that day they still not
they decided not to kill each other and
they kept the place alive walter what
was it like in the final like minute of
the game so that was that was a crazy
exchange
before the last drive
so you know we we had a like i'm sure
you guys saw the game there was a lot of
stops on both sides and you know so i
was nervous
stressed
um about a bunch of things like number
one obviously i don't want to lose the
game you know i i say i because i'm part
of the team
there is an in team no bet on i don't
bet normally but if i did if i were to
bet on the game i wouldn't bet on one
that i i'm watching because that would
yeah we've been on it because we're part
of the team yeah we're part of the ramps
and we all won collectively all five of
us won at joel i still won as a la as a
la rams lover that's pretty cool yeah
yeah
your face is so bitter right it lost
money even though he went against but
that was the best bet because then
i either win money or i win pride for
the city yeah and which one is more
important pride for this one pride and
money though that was sick
wait were you there when we when we made
this wager oh we made it collectively
because everyone was like oh let's go
[ __ ] bet for the rams because you
know they're the favorite and i'm like
yeah but what are the odds bet for the
rams because we're from l.a
no i was like what are the odds
and then the odds were like
you know you make like 50 bucks for
betting 200 or something yeah we bet 200
we made 137 we counted last night i was
like cool i'm always gonna i'm gonna bet
for the underdog because the [ __ ]
odds are way better so then they're like
well you go bet for the bengals then and
i was like fine i will [ __ ] you guys now
we split his money yup
and then here's my losing ticket right
here
what's it say it says all right ticket
cost
all right the red stamp
never bet again oh well with 200 bucks i
would have won 320 and the fourth
quarter was looking mighty good for
mangoes yeah it was scared i was so
scared and of course in my head i was
like of course joe would be i got really
happy for you for a second i was like
the last like minute is going to throw a
[ __ ] hail mary touchdown which almost
happened yeah yeah if it wasn't for
aaron i don't even watch until the
fourth quarter oh you didn't watch this
he wasn't watching the game no i took a
nap which of course she would beat us
yeah
he's like what happened who won and i
woke up in the first quarter and i
checked the score and i think toward the
end the second it was like
16
rams three bangles so i'm like uh there
goes my money and then i checked it
again and i'm like oh [ __ ] third
quarter's looking kind of nice and then
we started watching it around fourth and
then that was really intense oh yeah no
it was like i was nervous so because i
was nervous it was hard to enjoy the
game oh like that part but when i when i
went back home and watched the recording
i was like cheering like it was as if it
was new
yeah
like i was like yeah i'm sure people
walking my place like what's going
what's he doing
okay what about when odell got injured
he watched third and fourth quarter i'm
like why the [ __ ] is not odell not on
the field against the bengals last time
is when he got injured oh was it really
dude yeah so when you when you're at the
game there's no color commentary
so we don't really know we just know
he's not in the game yeah i mean we saw
him like hobble off the field and stuff
but we don't know why we don't know if
he's coming back because you know that
happens a lot they'll get injured they
come back we don't know um so it's only
like unless someone like some old man
has the radio oh yeah i want to do that
but i don't want to be you know like
like you're watching a game like this
yeah
because you know when you're when you're
an old man you can do like old people
you can wear black socks with sandals
and like it's just you're being ironic
it's funny at my age now if i do that
there's like oh that dude is old
you're young
yeah exactly let's just knock him out
that's the first instinct too when i see
someone like yeah right yeah i just want
to punch him you can't like so if i if i
go with headphones to listen to the game
it's a practical thing to do but then at
my age the way i look they'll be like
i'll look at that old man another old
man
trying to listen to the game so i don't
want to do that now you're like look at
that questionably moderate aged man yeah
exactly
middle age maybe if we're pushing it but
like so at the game we don't know so we
knew we knew odb i got injured but we
don't know to the extent until later we
find out unless like someone's listening
and then they tell someone like a young
person then the young person tells
everybody just screams it out oh yeah
we'll just then we'll like hear it oh
like odb
useful the odb like is injured and he's
not coming back then we'll know but
other than like barring that we don't
know so we're just like is it coach's
decision or like whatever so like i was
nervous
you know super bowl is once in a
lifetime you know unless you're like
uber wealthy it's once in a lifetime and
then it to have at your home your home
stadium that's once in the last cruise
and then to have your home team there
that i mean i know it's happened last
year but last year was the first time
for tampa bay and they won this year is
the second time and i don't know crazy
back to back like that nuts back to back
and it's it's extremely rare you know
and so people are probably thinking like
a casual fan saying oh this happens all
the time no like next year it's in vegas
it's at the raiders stadium will the
raiders make it probably not
but after they win their first game
they'll everyone will think raiders fans
will think it was going to happen it's
going to happen three times in a row but
raiders fans calm down it's just not
going to happen it's not going to happen
yeah tell them i haven't watched
football in a long time and seeing that
guy uh cooper yeah
i was like since when did white people
get good afternoon
today's video is brought to you by
curology all right look at his face
check this out okay
i
am an aging man and when i go to the
pharmacy
i see all of these products on the wall
for women women's skin care women this
whatever it's an unfair world but what
about me okay what if i want glistening
beautiful skin what if i i want
anti-aging cream what if i want to keep
my youthful looks well
thank goodness for curology so what's
pretty awesome about curology is it
takes all the thinking away
because it sets it up in a super super
duper easy way to do skin care for
example you go onto their website you
fill up a survey and then you go pick
what your goals are my goals anti-aging
cream i want something to look beautiful
maybe you got acne maybe you got dry
skin who knows but you could pick and
choose all those things and then a
licensed dermatology provider what
they're gonna do is muster up a formula
that's custom to you
and then you get this special little
package at your doorsteps so if you want
easy custom skin care
made specifically for you by a licensed
dermatology provider go to curology.com
and sign up for a free subscription all
you got to do is pay five dollars for
shipping and handling and that's a free
30-day trial and you could see how much
of the difference that it can make go to
curology.com
off the record to get your free 30-day
trial and i've been using it for two
years because they make it so simple for
me to use and that's why you still look
25 thank you
i'm 40.
ish
because
receivers are usually black yeah right
yeah no no no he's a quarterback i'm
talking about like like footballers
[Laughter]
not pretend baseballers yeah i'm talking
about footballers
[Music]
international sign of football right now
and i i think i honestly
and i'm i'm i'm taking a guess here so
don't cancel me for this you can cancel
me for other things but not for this i
feel like
that they don't cover cooper cup double
a triple team because he's white of
course right
that's right this guy can't juke nobody
yeah and then he actually gets away with
it forget about the fact that he led the
league in receptions he led the league
in yards he led the league in touchdowns
yeah forget about all that
but we don't need to double team him
yeah yeah and so that's why in our
conference championship game um
staffer was able to find him
play after play after play and then
super bowl there was no odb got injured
we don't our other receivers are like
secondary tertiary receivers there's no
one else it's going to cup every time
every time
every time every time it's a one season
thing like is he like the jeremy lin of
football no so he's been good he's big
it's like two seasons ago he got injured
or the last season got injured um and
then we had robert woods from usc fight
on but he got injured this year so there
we go we don't really have a primary
secondary receiver it's just like those
two guys are our main guys and because
they're both solid receivers they can't
really double one because the other
one's open but then when woods was uh
injured for the rest of the season i
thought they were in a double cooper cup
no and i think it's because he's white
they're like i got this guy like you we
don't need a double i got this guy so
remember how macaulay coconut was
playing for uh
the entire time we were watching the
game every time he threw it we'd be like
kevin
i just wanted to share that
speaking of yeah if you guys ever get a
chance to go to super bowl you should
definitely go i mean it's that's the
other thing i stressed about it was was
the prices of the tickets i was like oh
man
i paid that money and then we're gonna
lose does it hurt more i felt like it
was gonna hurt more but i know like
eventually i'd get over that part and
just be thankful that i got to go yeah
and because you know honestly it didn't
this going to the super bowl didn't
settle in and didn't set in fully until
after the game because the stress was
over we had one and then when i was
watching the highlights and i was when i
re-watched like parts of the super bowl
i was like oh yeah dude i was there but
what was it yourself and like i was
sitting right there you know
every time everything every time they
show the like where near me i'm like oh
they didn't go high enough
but look you look you got to be a part
of and i'm going to be the one to say
this sickest half-time show
i didn't even see that we're trying to
what's wrong we're trying to get that
[ __ ] to work we couldn't get it to work
it was like the [ __ ] sickest house it
was so good we started watching that
from third third quarter we're trying to
get we couldn't [ __ ] get to work you
know it's like there's this thing called
youtube nowadays right so i went on
youtube and i was trying to click on the
thing that thing and it wouldn't go they
have it now and and then and then i sent
it to them i was like dude you're using
this what was it about it is it because
of the nostalgia everything everything
everything that i also i also think well
yeah because
there's like nostalgia one but there's
also like they're from l.a yeah yeah so
like the power of that and then it's
rams and then it's in la so like the
power of that's extra the song selection
yeah the song selection at the end of
the day like those are all legendary
songs they're not just like old people
it's not like just seeing um they all
fat or like bastard boys
which would have probably been heaven
everyone's fatter except snoop it's the
funniest thing i know
i'll tell you okay so i answered your
question first from the end zone it
sucked oh because but but because you
see their backs
it's not even their backs because
they're facing the cameras so they're
facing they're on the 5th yard line
facing this side yeah and then kendrick
lamar was on the so i don't know so good
so there was those white things that
they were going up and down from i
thought that was a horrible setup
because if you're on behind them or on
the side in the end you can't see
anything
until drain snoop is on top and eminem
was on top you can see them
but basically we're all relying on the
screen but kendrick lamar was on the
other side so this side
couldn't see kendrick at all oh and then
this side couldn't see you know if when
like when like i think 50 was inside the
little cabinet things
so on the screen 50 looked a little bit
bigger but he didn't look that much
bigger so i didn't know what everyone
was talking about yeah and then when i
saw it on like when i saw it again i was
like oh my god dude that guy got huge
shoes i just think he looks like like
he's just white and he got big
everywhere like equally how do you do
that
usually usually it's your belly yeah or
it's you work out in your chest but he
got big everywhere he it was just like
nothing that's what happens when you get
shot nine times yeah dude
everything just do anything it's it's
like it's honestly it's like you know
that fat guy that just starts working
out yeah and then so the fat's still
there but the muscles underneath yeah
but it's like everywhere it's like he's
not working i got fat he's like you know
what oh we're gonna do super bowl i'm
gonna start working out right now
and like just like ballooned up dude and
he pulled pulled out his old wife beater
too
he's like going back in his old closet
bro
no he when he came on because it
transitioned from doctor dre to
physically
and then he comes under bro he's hanging
upside down and you're like what and
he's rapping upside down
bringing blood to his head
about him like setting up for like so
funny yeah i know even the mary j blige
once where she's laying on the floor
yeah did they get the wide shot there's
so many funny views with that she was
great too
she did awesome she was she was probably
my favorite part
like she killed it like like everyone
did well don't get me wrong everyone did
well but mary j blige i thought took it
to another another level it was just so
good did any of the older people like
look at the young crowd like that's real
hip hop you stupid [ __ ] yeah because
you can understand them they're not
mumbling you know and they're actually
doing it to the beat and they're making
music about something yeah i'll say
kendrick's is my favorite part of the
performance from a performance
standpoint in terms of what they were
doing with the boxes and everything like
that and just like being like in the
formations on the giant map of inglewood
yeah that was dope but i would say the
transition from eminem into still dre
using mob deep and stuff
damn the transition is what like because
usually like i was saying this when
we're watching the halftime show it's
like when you get this amount of star
power like you don't need to like make
those transitions so good yeah like you
just kind of phone it in exactly but the
transitions from song to song and they
cover all their basses i was just
getting [ __ ] hyped up and it was
crazy dude i'll tell you about the
carolina boxes so i have the end zone
view right and so you have those white
whatever you want to call those little
rooms or whatever and then you know
there's dancers in the front on this
side for the cameras they started
setting up boxes while they're
performing i'm like what are they doing
with boxes because they literally look
like cardboard boxes like what are they
are they getting ready are they
preparing to pack up
to leave you know that's what i thought
because they look like regular boxes you
know and then and then all of a sudden
you see these you know and i'm literally
called just call them brothers because
that's what they look like brothers were
coming out like what is going on over
there they're just getting black people
to pack up like they're preparing
and then then kendrick mark comes out it
will go because i can't see but he was
hiding in the box
they come out of the box and stuff so i
can't you know we can't see them because
they're they're smaller but
you know we see on the screen that's
kind of like they do their performance i
was like oh so cool they're not packing
up
they're setting up because like from my
perspective that's that's what we see
you know because we can't see much of
what's going on we rely on the screen
and i thought snoop his outfit was dope
because it was ram's colors
and you know it was just yeah the whole
the whole cripping all the way too oh
yeah and they all sound really good
still oh these yeah they sound amazing
sound just like what what they what
they're supposed to tell them
i love i love eminem live
and so like i thought he killed it but
mary j blige like and the sound system
is so far is phenomenal oh if you ever
get a chance to go to a concert there
i'm sure it's amazing the sound system
is awesome and so dude the whole place
was just like bumping no one really no
you didn't really see people leave even
like old people like old people were
staying that's cool i saw like they know
the music that's yeah
i saw some of the football players came
out just to enjoy oh really oh yeah i
didn't see that they didn't go like i
totally would have if i was them too
like that's like also your people's like
music you know what i'm saying like
these fools were probably born when that
album was coming out they're probably
born to that album are we that old yeah
chronic 2001 that was 21 years ago the
son of a [ __ ]
the best tweet i saw was someone goes
i'm so glad the super bowl they didn't
have like one of those old groups like
rolling stones oh wait
i'm old like you know like this one it
was one of those like when are you gonna
see though um like a legendary group
like collection i was like avengers
posted on his instagram they had someone
edited the avenger with their faces with
the faces of them that was great even
though it's weird that they put dr dre
as hawkeye in that one but you know
someone had to be him i thought that was
like iron man but you know whatever the
halftime show was like you know people
are some people calling it the best ever
really it's up there dude the michael
jackson one was pretty simple jason to
me is still among the best
i was like too young to really
understand that [ __ ] i feel like this
one because you're like old and you're
watching you're like
[ __ ] that's so good yeah yeah probably
especially in la right like for all the
la folks like that was one of the
coolest things yeah but that's something
we all shared even like you know um i
don't know if there's any reference to
the younger group now like even people
that are like in their early twenties
now
well actually you know anderson
and then anderson pack was playing drugs
yeah dude that was crazy too he was up
there he was playing drums for her for
eminem yeah that was really cool it was
really him i was making a joke i was
like dude check out anderson pack and
people like that's anderson it says it
on the drum set that was also an email a
picture of him just playing it's like yo
anderson pack showing up just to play
drums is such a mood oh yeah
he was also the only guy in like a
really brightly colored shirt for the
band
that's
what a moment you still haven't watched
it i don't want to watch it i'm going to
watch the whole thing okay dude
and you report back after you watch it
okay i'm gonna go to sofi when it's
empty and i'm gonna [ __ ] put it at
the
angle to make it look like a 50-yard
line
the funny thing with the halftime shows
that you hear you see a lot of you heard
a lot of parents be like our kids
finally um found out what their parents
were like like dancing and stuff because
a lot of parents got to start dancing
because for them
that's what they grew up to and so they
were feeling it you know because these
are these are the like you know as you
guys don't know classic iconic songs
they didn't they didn't do like the
b-side song but like only like
hip-hop heads like promote a new single
yeah they did the mainstream one that
everyone knows i wonder if the kids are
like damn my parents said what do you
thinks they're as [ __ ] yeah what the
[ __ ] or like i never knew my parents
could dance or like some kids like i
never knew my parents danced and i they
shouldn't ever dance again you know i
know how to [ __ ] walk yeah
what set my dad was from
did you know you were rolling 60s
you